hello hi of the shin one Hank you know I
I'm I am Yuto hello
I'm Thuy hello I am pencil I am Jin ho
I am Yohan let's play no I think it's
not because of the dance it's because of
his characters yeah to give the honor to
the ones no no no no you're York you go
you first okay let me know the reason
why you choose yourself
this is reason he's I owned the first
price think yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
you know I think on stage
he later he is good performance Papa
more that but offstage he's an idiot
he's a comedian only oh yeah
keno is exercise the conjecture well you
don't know what you mean
yeah enjoy Maura yeah you don't go
together as one and salami what rich guy
no I'm not rich
thank you but our members all of our
members are good at fashion except rich
I think except you two oh no no no all
members are good good
I did I mean oh yeah
like it I think when here take a shower
he always produces its face expression
sure sure yeah I show them a facial
expression hey sexy very sexy
three two one those are treat them
they're just a little bit me yeah I want
your fortune yeah hold on you have
chocolate on his stomach for always
prepare absolutely he has I have
explained this yeah hey eight pack yeah
yeah so very gorgeous
[Laughter]
[Music]
Paul's got one in New York I'm going I
want to go home yeah when you in cave
I'm on stage
yeah
and not me okay okay it's not not you
don't good physical power mental no no
no no like your bank account thank you
for watching
strength comes out of his bank accounts
yeah yeah yeah money power yesterday I
tried a tragic we had a concert in
Toronto Canada and he he prepared a
phrase like a joke for for I'm thrown to
fans but he actually missed the chance
so he's trying to do it right yeah yeah
please the reaction okay yeah you are a
Canadian and I'm comedian I often do not
touch my phone no no always what's the
point
from now on I will change good
[Music]
oh wait that's not true
yeah T cousin in the mansion here to do
tenancy will the communit my acting is
good a few days ago it was my birthday
and hello on give me surprise gift and
I'm so my heart I'm so touched
maybe she's ready Thank You Marty
[Music]
whistles Oh show me who's ox hi not is
it's like almost like dolphins yeah is
high note is usable yeah you're so
useful yeah sure show them yeah useful
voice well thank you so much we loved
who's who
we're having a tour right now so if you
guys are interested come to our show and
enjoy the show please thank you bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]